I Married an Indian girl the only time I
regretted was planting the Indian
wedding that was where I was like I
should have married a white because a
white wedding was a very simple Affair
it happens in like a [__] Farm
oh okay so you got married in a slightly
less white Place Churchill what is
Churchill is that like a racetrack
that's even whiter
how did you get whiter than a farm
you're from Kentucky yeah you can't
marry no black guy in a farm in Kentucky
that would give him PTSD
[Laughter]
get the [__] out of here that's
beautiful man what do you do for a
living
God damn that's exactly what your
parents tried to do
beautiful thing dude we really carried
on the condition